we don't have to like our jobs every day
but we do get to love our jobs every day
like you don't like your children every
day but you love your children every day
so having a this a hard day you know
that that's fine but the question is is
what do we fall in love with and at the
end of the day the reason um uh that we
stay or leave a job is because of how we
feel about that job you know i think we
we misunderstand when we think people
just leave for money if they just leave
for money then they never really had
strong feelings of the company in the
first place right because when people
feel
loyal to the company they turn down jobs
that offer them more money or
if it's so tempting and the numbers are
so high then they go to their company
and say listen
i was offered this job
it's very tempting there's a lot of
pressure but i don't want to leave is
there anything you can do to help me
stay
right so and you and there's the point
is is there they're open about it
and and what makes people want to have
that conversation like i said is that
they're seen and heard
the best companies
um have all kinds of programs inside the
company to help the person grow as an
individual now we talked about you know
listening skills and these kinds of
things these are valuable for the work
that we do but it turns out that those
skills
also help us as parents and they help us
as as spouses or as boyfriends and as
girlfriends these are valuable skills in
life
you know
and i think that we forget that we talk
about hard skills and soft skills as if
those things are opposite it's a terror
i hate the term soft skills hard skills
and human skills and the more that we
invest in human skills in addition to
the hard skills that we're teaching the
more people feel
like they're growing as individuals i'm
a better version of myself now than i
was when i started at this company
because the company is actually helping
me on a in personal growth
um
uh wd-40 which is a company that i
admire their their culture uh the
lubricant company
they train their managers to be coaches
so literally like executive coaching
training that kind of thing but they
train their own people to do to have
that skill set so that they're equipped
to help their people who have challenges
and especially with younger generation
you know the younger generation is
asking companies to provide everything
you know we want to have our sense of
belonging our sense of community our
sense of personal growth our sense of
purpose to come from work it didn't used
to be like that 40 years ago
and so and so there's a huge pressure on
companies and so i think what entices
people into the company into the
industry is not just come and do cyber
security you know there's a percentage
of people who are you know de facto
interested in that but rather tell them
the kind of experience they're going to
have tell them what they get from the
company and you'll find it remarkable
how many people will all of a sudden be
interested in the in the category in the
company because of what they get
holistically not just what they get from
the product